[Music]
on this friday night tragedy strikes the
royal military college four cadets
killed and the mystery of how their car
ended up in the water the mission to
free thousands trapped in a mario paul
steel mill we are doing everything we
can as the people of kyiv suffer more
brutality from moscow
rolling thunder ottawa
is still a go the protesting bikers
riding into our nation's capital making
locals nervous
and she's unstoppable
you look like you can't believe it you
look happy
a canadian jeopardy champion who just
can't lose
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
says another mass grave has been
discovered he says the unconfirmed
number of bodies were found in an area
on the outskirts of kiev it's unclear
how many were there but about 900 bodies
have been discovered since the war began
the gruesome discovery comes as
officials fear civilians in hiding can't
go much longer without food and water
some say they've been without
electricity for weeks
and mariupol's mayor is asking russia to
show some humanity to allow people
including children to safely leave the
city and a nearby industrial complex at
the same time intense fighting in the
eastern donbass region has led to more
casualties on both sides redmond shannon
has tonight's top story
this video released by ukraine's as of
battalion claims to show the aftermath
of a shelling attack on a field hospital
inside the azov style steel works this
week
it's thought about one thousand
civilians and two thousand ukrainian
soldiers are still inside the facility
the last holdout of ukrainian forces in
the port city of mariupol
the unit's deputy commander says if
russia's military wants to save face
they will allow the united nations in
here to evacuate civilians i can only
tell you we are doing
everything we can
to make it happen un secretary general
antonio guterres gave little detail on
the plan when meeting with vladimir
zelinski thursday the ukrainian
president's office said they hope to
attempt an evacuation friday there is no
word on its progress
thousands of kilometers away in rome the
refugee wives of azov soldiers are not
holding out much hope he said that
situation is horrible and that the
russians are bombing as hostile every
day many many corridors were attacked by
russians and i don't believe them
outside the plant there are an estimated
100 000 civilians also trapped in the
city as the war rages around them
ukraine conceding it is suffering heavy
troop losses across the donbass region
but it insists that russian casualties
are even higher
there are sadly also more civilian
deaths
this woman's 14 year old grandson was
killed when their home was hit by
russian fire
he asked grandma will i live i said that
he would but look what happened i
betrayed him i am alive and he is not
and another escalation friday russia's
defense ministry publishing video of
what it says are cruise missiles fired
from one of its black sea submarines
the first time they've been used since
the war began in february redmond
shannon global news london
finland and sweden say as the war goes
on the two countries will deepen their
military cooperation with each other
whether they apply for nato membership
or not
the overall impression is that if sweden
and finland apply there will be a
positive it will be positively received
by the nato members not the least
because sweden and finland would then be
net contributor of security
russia has threatened serious
consequences if finland and sweden join
nato neither country has stated an
intention to do so so far
some people have returned home to keeve
under the impression it's safe to do so
but many are having second thoughts
after two missiles launched by russia
smashed into the city a journalist's
body was found this morning in the
rubble and as crystal gummensing reports
nowhere in ukraine is out of harm's way
twisted heaps of metal slabs of fallen
concrete and workers scrambling to clear
away pieces of several buildings
the destruction caused by missiles
thursday night a reminder that russia
is not finished with keith
my daughter and i viewed the kitchen and
there was an explosion at the time i
first saw a flash and then heard the
sound pavlov kozetsky just returned with
his family a few days ago thinking it
was safe his youngest child thought the
thud of the missile striking a building
near his was thunder
his older children understand ukraine
has been dragged into a war
we are very angry our country is under
attack from russia
and i agreed to fight against this
country for sake of my daughters at
least eight buildings in the
shefchenkiewski district in the capital
sustained damages in the strikes one
woman a journalist vera hewitch was
killed in her home
russia claims it used five precision
missiles and destroyed a weapons factory
workshop
as the largest land war in europe since
the second world war stretches on and
more lives are lost the level of anger
rises
i will collect molotov cocktails just in
case and we will remove those bandits
from our country and we will remember
everyone
maintaining a fighting spirit is not
easy especially when you've lost your
home stronghold
i saw a plane it was not scaring me but
now i have a fear anastasia invited
global news into her bombed out building
in european but didn't feel up to
appearing on camera she says she's
salvaging what she can
and feels better
we recently bought this apartment
and we really like the city the city
became very close to us
european is just outside of kiev in
mid-march people started fleeing because
of shelling but many were killed or
wounded on the roads trying to escape
russian forces the area was held for a
short time as russia prepared to descend
on the capitol
infrastructure in previously occupied
areas is a major problem do you want me
to open this so i can see this was the
bridge if you can call it that that we
use to leave the city
some of the infrastructure was destroyed
by russia other parts were taken out by
ukrainians trying to delay the troops
from getting to keep
roads utilities even water is still in
the process of being restored in many
areas in cities such as european and
bucha city officials are encouraging
businesses to reopen so people can
access supplies to rebuild or at least
patch things up and make them livable
with the renewed attacks here in kiev
the question is
is it too soon
chris
crystal gomezing in kiev thanks very
much crystal
now mystery surrounds a late night
tragedy on the campus of royal military
college in kingston ontario four cadets
were killed sean o'shea joins us from
kingston with what we've learned so far
sean
chris what we know is that four cadets
have died and the questions now are how
could they have ended up in a vehicle in
the water here behind me that is the
royal military college just behind me
historic royal military college founded
in 1874.
classes are over exams are done but the
students are still on campus and four
cadets were in that vehicle ended up in
the water and died now the department of
national defense is not saying a whole
lot about this
but about two hours ago
the vehicle was pulled out using a crane
from the water
just at the edge here and now the
investigation to be conducted by
the department of national defense
primarily will begin the dnd issued a
statement uh including
some sympathy for the families and for
the victims saying in part their
priority is to ensure that naval and
officer cadets staff and families are
cared for and supported they said this
loss is felt across the rmc community
saying they extend their deepest
condolences to all members their
families and their friends during this
difficult time now the royal military
college campus is located at point
frederick on the peninsula just slightly
southeast of the city of kingston that's
where lake ontario meets the st lawrence
river and that's where we are right now
chris
sean i know it's tough to read anything
from the color of a vehicle but it
certainly seemed to be that deep
military green is there any indication
that they were in a dnd vehicle and and
what they might have been doing at 2 am
in the morning there
it's possible it was a d vehicle it's
too early to tell in the department of
natural defense as i said being very
tight-lipped about this not saying much
at all beyond the very basics and this
investigation in its early stages but a
tragedy here in kingston at an
institution that is well known and many
known graduates here uh it's a very
important uh institution here and a lot
of questions to be asked in the days
ahead chris no doubt thanks for your
coverage that's shawn o'shea in kingston
ontario thank you sean
tension in the nation's capital as the
city prepares for a weekend of
demonstrations linked to the so-called
freedom convoy protests that brought
downtown ottawa to a standstill this
time hundreds of motorcycles are rolling
into town dan spector is in ottawa for
us and dan what's the biker's message
and is it something police see as a
threat
chris the bikers say they want to bring
dignity back to the national war
memorial they're upset with how it was
fenced in at some times during the
convoy protests so they are coming to do
that and they're planning to be here in
great numbers tomorrow how many will
actually show up we'll have to wait and
see but there are just they are just one
of them multiple groups coming here to
the nation's capital to protest this
weekend just behind me people are
gathering for a rally associated with
the freedom fighters canada group and
yes police are taking this very
seriously they are deploying in great
numbers and uh employing some
interesting strategies in what promises
to be a very loud weekend
it's set to be the warmest weekend of
the spring and ottawa residents don't
want anything to interrupt it the route
has been planned and
we hope they're just in and out rolling
thunder ottawa
is still a go neal sheard is a canadian
forces veteran and was a prominent voice
from this year's occupation now he's
inviting veterans and others to join
rolling thunder ottawa on the national
war memorial saturday morning they'll be
on motorcycles and plan to meet just
outside ottawa city center before moving
toward parliament hill give back dignity
to
the monument
and give dignity back to the veterans
though sheared and other groups involved
are advocating for peaceful
demonstrations police are preparing for
more this time police have established a
motor vehicle exclusion zone
protesters will not be allowed to drive
into the downtown core the rcmp has been
in touch with a local ottawa police
service and is providing
additional resources several tow trucks
have already arrived the plan is to bar
any vehicles related to the protest from
getting close to the war memorial or
parliament hill i think the response is
better this weekend is going to be a
test for them brian letour is organizing
a counter protest he thinks rolling
thunder is using veterans to obscure
what he believes the group really
represents this gathering here on
parliament hill is growing by the second
chris people gathering with canadian
flags and a lot of signs with similar
slogans to what we saw during the the
convoy protest they will end the evening
with a march through the byword market
and we'll just have to wait and see how
things develop tomorrow back to you
we'll definitely keep an eye on it dan
specter in ottawa thank you dan
canada becomes a player in global
vaccine production coming up the plans
for a new plant and the promise of mrna
medicine beyond covet
plus the dying dream of home ownership
what gen z is doing for housing instead
canada that has long been leaders in
research around mrna will now be also
leaders in delivering mrna to canadians
and to the worlds with this investment
prime minister trudeau announcing
montreal as the new home for the
promised moderna vaccine production
plant it'll be the company's first
factory in canada as many as 300 people
are expected to work at the facility to
produce up to a hundred million mrna
vaccine doses a year it will also help
secure long-term supply of covet 19
vaccines in this country
construction on the plant is scheduled
to begin this year and wrap up by 2024.
now moderna has also asked health canada
to authorize its pediatric covit 19
vaccine for children aged six months to
under six years of age as eric sorenson
reports it covers an age group barred
from getting a shot since the vaccine
rollout began in canada in late 2020
gisele cherie's son aiden is almost
three and she has spent much of his
young life worrying about him getting
kovid and hoping for a vaccine i just
want to protect him from getting sick or
if he does
that still gets sick i want to protect
him from you know any severe outcomes
moderna is the first vaccine maker to
ask health canada to authorize a low
dose of its spike vacs for children as
young as six months and up to age six
who've not till now been eligible
they're still a big unmet medical need
so i think we need we're seeing cases in
children raising so i think we need to
give the option to parents to vaccinate
their children infectious disease
doctors are delighted because kids are
at risk in the current wave of kovid
we've had a number of kids younger kids
die
and so
so that's protection of the children but
also protection of the families the
older you are the more likely you've had
at least one vaccine dose as of this
month canadians over 60 are more than 95
percent vaccinated younger adults
including teenagers are close to 90
percent and children 5 to 11 have only
just been receiving vaccines recently
are at 57 percent but kids up to the age
of four are close to zero so vaccinating
that group can only add to the country's
overall immunity but for some parents
there is reluctance emily borghese is
vaccinated but her child is only six
months old and they've both had covid i
had omicron it wasn't that bad so i
don't think she needs it it's not worth
the risk in a statement health canada
says it will only authorize spike vax if
its independent and thorough scientific
review of the data shows the benefits of
the vaccine outweigh the risks in this
age group the approval process could
last several weeks we have full
confidence that the application will
look at in the very best way and doctors
say if the drug is safe the greater risk
would be not vaccinating children the
risk of long-term side effects on the
kids is negligible compared to the risk
of children getting cold and getting
sick with it and transmitting it to
other vulnerable people gisele cherie
doesn't need convincing i'm looking
forward for for this to be over aren't
we all
erik sorensen global news toronto
little hope for home ownership just
ahead why more young canadians are
giving up on the market
canada's economy grew more than expected
in february as pandemic restrictions
eased the gdp increased just over one
percent the largest monthly gains since
march 2021 80 percent of industries saw
growth the biggest jump was in urban
public transit it soared 24 percent
food and accommodation services rose
more than 15 percent the economic growth
is adding to pressure for the bank of
canada to hike interest rates again to
help cool things down
but it's a move that could make buying a
home even harder and as ann gaviola
reports home ownership is already a
distant dream for many canadians
there are signs that the housing market
that was on a tear during the pandemic
is taking a breather but the damage may
already be done for many who would hope
to get in eventually polling by ipsos
exclusively for global news shows more
than 60 percent of respondents hoping to
get into the market are now giving up
it's going to continue to percolate as
housing prices rise inflation continues
and interest rates go up people in bc
and ontario home to the least affordable
housing markets feel most resigned to
renting or living with their parents the
dream hasn't been dashed everywhere
though in saskatchewan manitoba and the
atlantic provinces it lives on for the
majority
there are generational divides too
respondents under 35 say owning a home
is less important now than it was a
quarter century ago a sentiment not
shared as widely by older generations
and opinions differ when it comes to
outside the box solutions to home
ownership
younger canadians are most likely to be
open to co-ownership with family and
friends with three out of every four gen
z respondents and nearly 60 percent of
millennials saying their game to
purchase with others a lot of people are
looking at the home ownership question
in a new way as you said considering
other alternatives like buying a home
with somebody else or a partnership or
even just putting their money somewhere
else the federal budget pledged 10
billion dollars to help boost the supply
of affordable housing over the next five
years there's also a tax rebate for
first-time homebuyers to a maximum of
forty thousand dollars which doesn't go
far in markets like toronto and
vancouver seventy-five percent of
respondents say these measures won't
make enough of a difference and
economists agree in terms of
ownership costs with interest rates
rising things are going to get even more
difficult ann gaviola global news
toronto
18 well-earned wins and counting where
canadian matteo roach ranks among
jeopardy's greatest next
[Music]
reigning jeopardy champ mateo roach
scored her 18th straight win last night
the most of any canadian contestant ever
the 23 year old from halifax has won
nearly half a million dollars so far and
doesn't seem to have a weakness and as
mike drollet shows us matea is
positioning herself right up among the
show's greatest players of all time
who is yates
with just seconds to spare you wrote
down the correct response
and did you wager anything one dollar
matia roach kept her fans on the edge of
their seats this week winning one game
by a dollar what is song of solomon by
tony morrison that's correct and turning
a close game into a blowout with another
obscure answer you look like you can't
believe it you look happy believe it
that last win her 18th straight thrusts
the nova scotia-raised torontonian into
the pantheon of all-time jeopardy greats
ken jennings who is now a part-time host
is considered the goat or greatest of
all time after winning 74 games in a row
amy schneider with 40 wins matt emodio
at 38 and james holthauer at 32 make up
the mount rushmore of super champions
and then there's matea who just needs
two more wins to move up to fifth all
time is it too soon to start making
comparisons between her and some of our
other great season 38 super champions
oddly enough both schneider and emoji's
win streaks occurred this season so
roach will eventually face them in the
tournament of champions and since
jeopardy keeps statistics on everything
there's proof she's in their league
and when it comes to accuracy her 92
percent correct response rate is right
between matt's 90 percent and amy's 95
and why not she not only holds the
record for most wins by a canadian she's
also the youngest super champion ever
how long can she keep this streak going
we know the answer will come in the form
of a question mike crowley global news
toronto
well done mattia that is global national
for this friday night i'm chris galas
tonight's your canada is the
saskatchewan legislative building in
regina please keep your emails coming
send your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks very much for
watching nitu garcia will be with you
tomorrow hope you have a great weekend
[Music]